Okay, Michael, what's the answer?
>> So, alright. Does it make sense to repeat, an attribute along a path in
the tree? So, it seems like it could be no, [SOUND] in that, you know,
if we're looking at attributes like, you know, is a true, then later we would
ask again is a true because we would already have known the answer to that.
>> Right, and by the way, information
gain will pick that for you automatically.
>> It doesn't have to be a special thing in the algorithm,
if, if, you consider, an attribute that you've already split on, then you're not
going to gain any information, so it's going to be the worst thing, to split on.
>> Exactly.
>> Alright, but it,
>> Okay, doing good.
>> But it seems like maybe you're trying to lead us
on because ,this we're in the continuous attributes portion of our show.
>> Okay, well what's the answer there? Is the answer not also false?
>> Well we wouldn't want to ask the
same question, about the same attribute. So,
we wouldn't have age, between 20 an 30, and then later ask again, age ,between
20 and 30. But ,maybe we want to ask, you know, given that we are less than 20,
we're, are we teenagers or not, so we might
have a different range, on age later in the tree.
>> So, that's exactly right, Michael. So, the answer is
no, it does not make sense ,to repeat an attribute along
a path of the tree, for discrete, value trees. However, for
continuous [UNKNOWN] attributes, it does
make sense. Because, what you're actually
doing, is asking a different question. So, one way to think
about this, is that the question is age in the 20's
or not. Is actually ,a discreet valued attribute that you've just
created, for the purposes of the decision tree. So, asking that
question doesn't make sense but asking a different question, about age,
does in fact make sense. So ,once you know, that you
are not in the 20's you might ask well am I
less than, 20 years old? Maybe a teenager or am I greater
than 40. How old am I, 44? Greater than 44, in which case, I'm old.
>> So if it's, if you ask, [LAUGH] the
tree that you drew isn't quite right though, right?
>> Yeah, it is.
>> because, if you go down the false branch, it means you are less than 20.
>> No, I can be greater than 30.
>> Oh, good one.
>> Yes, I'm very clever, or at least I accidentally got it right.
One of the two, it's the same thing. Okay, so there you go.